I worry you know Tracy Morgan I love the
guy he's always on our show he bought
another new car 2012 that's 2 million
brand-new probably 5 million the run why
is this car 2 million dollars and what
is that why why in other words what car
could be justifiably 2 million dollars
I'm why well it's handmade first of all
the car and buy handmade you mean that
guys like bang out the engine and by
hand well it usually means one guy
yeah well it's more than one guy I mean
it's a couple of guys but they stayed
but the station is a separate job to do
on the car watch when they build it but
it's hid the car is handmade it's not
like it goes to an assembly line when
you say hey I made how far do they go
with that like in other words so they
have a guy forging out like the metal
and yeah oh yeah metal yeah and they
make them making the seats you know
everything well you know it's they got
the leather they saw it they do it
exactly in its special leather it comes
from special cows and Wow yeah all right
thanks rambha no problem yeah what's up
Frank Frank from Florida Robin hey no
you know I know Ronnie's your go-to guy
for cars and car questions I've never
heard somebody in the radio know less
about cars oh yeah I need a limo driver
what did he get wrong it's just clueless
you asked him if they're you know
banging sheet metal out hand by hand who
to put these cars together he's yeah
yeah yeah yeah like he's just ridiculous
he knows nothing about cars so Ronnie
doesn't know what he's talking about by
cars you are so full of [ __ ] dude why
you're out of your mind man they're
hand-built but it's not they're not
gonna stumble on but they're no one's
banging out of fender for a Bugatti I
mean that you know they're molding the
actual body and everything which is done
by one or two different people what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
that's about what he asked you that's
not the question he asked you Ronnie you
can see is this usual no I'm not
confused as usual he's saying Ronnie
you're wrong about the book whatever
he's right because he says he's right
maybe Frank will be my new expert
[ __ ] Frank : Fred who's right these
cars are hand built these cars take I
think at least a month the even problem
what does that mean how far do we go and
we're hand-built and I know there's two
guys that build the engine and they
probably do it but not in Game of
Thrones may not however assembling it by
hand which means they probably have put
wrenches on it and they're torquing it
though it's not a machine that's doing
that correct and that's what I said
[ __ ] no that's not what I said [ __ ]
face was banging out of no I didn't say
that [ __ ] I said they molded the body
they mold out the body you jerk-off how
is the body made any fun
the bodies are made all the same that's
it there's no they're not no they're not
no no no those cars not one car is
exactly the same absolutely we do yeah
go [ __ ] yourself you don't know do you
know the guys who build the car yeah you
know the guys who build the car one guy
his name is boo any other guy's name is
God he get it boo
why did JD cancel your car show I have
no idea do you want to take away Ronnie
show permanent cancel the [ __ ] show
I'm sorry sorry what sorry what show's
canceled they should have kept this
doesn't know what he's [ __ ] talking
about you have to ask JD JD he put the
hammer down and had no problem with it
[Music]
in other words all that other [ __ ]
you could do without the fight you like
yeah I wouldn't want to hear that either
right did you call it quote the most
boring a show ever
can you revamp the show and bring it
back you know what it is I think he
needs me there with him to just keep him
on track with arguing and then he needs
Fred there is Fred Ronnie race car you
[ __ ] maybe what I'm thinking of doing
is now that the company owns Pandora I
might do an hour podcast which me and
Ronnie and the Fred Ronnie and we just
take our questions would you listen to
that absolutely